Bonjour Brut, c'est le même bateau que
j'ai l'opportunité d'avoir une expérience qui a changé ma vie,
eh bien, c'est certainement quand j'ai
commencé à suivre le terrain, je veux dire que je
cliquais amoureux, c'était ce que je jouais
et pour moi quand mon entraîneur a décidé que mon
entraîneur de cricket m'a dit de faire
l'athlétisme c'est là que ma vie a
vraiment changé parce que pour moi c'est un
sport que je finis par faire et dont je gagne ma
vie Je n'aurais jamais su
que je serais en désaccord parce que j'ai
commencé je viens de commencer à vérifier Pinellas
Ted
[Musique]
à 15 ans, quand j'ai gagné le mot maladie
devant ma propre foule pour moi, c'était
une autre expérience qui a changé ma vie parce
que c'était vraiment le début de ma
domination et que ce n'était pas
bien pour moi, c'était l'une de mes
courses les plus stressantes  J'ai mis le mauvais tu as
tort Sean autour du pied parce que je
ne pouvais pas me concentrer j'étais tellement nerveux et à partir de
là je me suis dit qu'il n'y a aucune
raison d'être nerveux si je peux gagner
devant mon public je peux gagner
devant des inconnus donc pour moi t
ça m'a aidé à changer ma vie et à tourner une nouvelle
page
[Applaudissements]
ça m'est venu à l'esprit c'était un peu une
danse en Jamaïque
qui s'appelait dans le monde et
j'ai juste mis la touche dessus et je l'ai
fait mienne et c'est  tout cela est devenu
quelque chose qui a encore changé ma vie
parce que maintenant tout le monde me connaît par ça les
gens pour moi c'est tout ce que vous
savez je veux dire c'est une marque parce que même
parfois les gens ne connaissent même pas mon nom
mais si je fais la pose ils le
reconnaîtront oh ouais  tu es le coureur ouais et
c'étaient des membres qui ont définitivement
changé ma vie parce
que c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai été vraiment
reconnu dans le monde entier maintenant et j'ai commencé
à faire des mouvements et à faire du bien ouais je
ne le savais même pas  J'ai apporté un
disque et aimer 20 minutes après quand
je l'ai entendu par l'interphone si j'avais
pensé mon dieu que vous disiez pleurer pour moi
j'étais choqué parce que pour moi j'étais juste
là pour concourir c'était contre Tyson
Gay et pour moi c'était  une grande course et
la fa  ct que j'ai gagné, j'étais juste heureux alors
quand j'ai ramené le record de ce
n'était qu'un bonus mais c'était
vraiment un gros problème
[Applaudissements] de
grands événements dans ma vie pour chaque étude olympique,
je pense que je ne l'ai pas fait - mon  héritage mon
premier était grand parce que c'était mon
premier défendre mes titres étaient grands
parce que j'étais la première personne à avoir jamais
défendu un titre de 120 mètres et ensuite
gagner à Rio était énorme parce qu'il
n'a jamais été tenté de gagner elle
n'a fait que cornichon  batailles donc pour moi oublie ça
dos à dos pour moi c'était grand
pour moi m'a fait pourquoi j'ai fait de moi une
chanson de légende
toi